it's been a year overshadowed by loss
for each grieving family the loss of one
person is one too many months after he
was killed his seat at the table remains
empty the eldest of five siblings dad
went to school and never came home
Israeli forces shot him in albire in the
occupied West Bank
no matter how hard she tries his mother
Maria says no words can express her pain
foreign but I want to know why he was
killed it's a simple ask the area was
cam no confrontations children were
going home after school children who
never fulfilled their dreams
it wasn't the only Palestinian killed on
May the 11th
Israeli forces shot Al Jazeera
journalist chirin in the head while she
was on assignment in Janine
the veteran reporter was described by
many as the daughter of Palestine
you've done it shireen's farewell
stretched across more than 140
kilometers from Janine to Ramallah to
our final resting place and occupied is
Jerusalem
and then perhaps some of the most
shocking scenes in the Occupy territory
this year
the attack on Paul bearers at chirin's
funeral
in midst of global contamination
Palestinians demanded action the
silencing of opposition when we're
discussing human rights Defenders which
include journalist paramedics or any
other Palestinian so not necessarily
working in civil study organizations is
as a way of maintaining the apartheid
regime and in essence the apartheid
regime as we see it today
is a tool of enforcing China subtle
coronalism Palestinians have told us if
they had to choose one word to sum up
2022 it would be oppression
but remember those who were killed by
posting their photos online displaying
their pictures on walls and talking
about them their images became part of
public spaces
Palestinians say that without Justice
and accountability
Collective mourning helps families
through their grief
Ibrahim al-jazeera the occupied West
Bank